what is the General Secretariat of the
council also known as the GRC it is a
body of staff that supports two
institutions the European Council and
the Council of the EU as well as their
presidencies its role is to help
organize and ensure the coherence of the
council's work the GSC has a wide
variety of tasks it organizes and
supports over 4,000 meetings every year
at all levels from civil servants to
ministers to heads of state or
government it prepares the documents
needed before and after these meetings
including agendas reports or draft laws
it registers archives and translates
these documents it gives legal advice to
the institutions it serves and
communicates on their activities the GRC
also manages the budget for both
institutions which is around 0.4 percent
of the total EU budget to achieve all
this to the highest standard the GSC can
count on its 2,800 staff members coming
from all over the EU policy officers and
technical experts IT communicational
translation professionals work at all
levels in the different GSD departments
their work is based on the principles of
Independence and professionalism in at
least two official languages the GSC is
led by its secretary-general who is
appointed by the council find out more
about the GRC and much more on Concilium
zero / gu